jeudi soir
voilà casimir career ou alors il m'a
l'air bien a ajouté il doit avoir une
bonne nouvelle à vous annoncer parce que
quand ça va mal il est très discret
bonjour tous la gueule aujourd'hui quasi
vie j'ai vous savez pas quoi une bonne
nouvelle à nous annoncer ça alors mais
comment avez vous deviné tu sais tu as
du mal à faire des surprises quand tu es
vraiment content c'est vrai chaque fois
je me dis il faut que je prenne des
résultats les plus j'approche dujardin
plus j'ai envie de courir et de danser
je crois que tous nos amis condren c'est
très bien il leur arrive exactement la
même chose à chaque fois qu'ils veulent
faire une bonne surprise alors
maintenant ou leurs patins pour une
personne qu'ils aiment beaucoup n'est ce
pas c'est vraiment je suis bien content
de ne pas être le seul et à propos que
les sbires
vous connaissez monsieur beauchemin sur
le marchand de meubles de l'île aux
enfants c'est ça il est même très gentil
et bien il m'a offert le moindre que je
voulais pour ma maison ici c'est
fantastique uk l'honneur parce que je
l'ait aidée à déménager tout son hangar
de meubles tous les mains oui et alors
sommes très fiers de toi mais tu dois
être très fatigué pas tellement pourtant
casimir les meubles sont des choses très
lourde c'est vrai tu sais françois que
casimir est devenu très fort ne put il
fait les exercices de danse
désunir
quel est le meuble le plus lourd était
transporté fin a aucun comment quand
j'écris ces lignes je l'expliqué
casimir veut dire qu'il ne transportait
aucun meuble très lourd parce que
monsieur beauchesne ne lui a confié que
des petits meubles très léger tu n'as
rien compris du tout françois comme
d'habitude merci quand même écoute c
simple même si jaunards et transporter
que les morgues le léger il aurait bien
le parmi eux un meuble plus lourd que
les autres c'est vrai bon alors ma
réponse était claire si j'étais a
répondu aucun c'est que je n'ai
transporté au câble alors c'est moi qui
ne comprend plus rien du tout maintenant
noyer a longtemps que j'ai abandonné ce
que tu peux m'expliquer quelque chose
comment as tu pu déménager
avec monsieur bush un immeuble de son
hangar sans emporter aucun set oui c'est
tout c'est très sage je me suis assis
dans un grand fauteuil très confortable
et chaque fois que monsieur beauchesne
passé avec un gros meubles je
l'encourageais en criant oh hisse au 10e
bien alors je lui disais basique chaîne
rasy beauchesne basée alors ça m'a
beaucoup amusé il arrive le temps est
passé très vite pour lui et au réconfort
il m'a offert le meuble que je voulais
je reconnais que nous étions bien loin
de tout ça et elle me v'là t'y cheville
c'est là mon problème je ne sais pas
quel meuble choisir
par là c'est bien ça gaz inerte
qu'est-ce que ça c'est moi je te croyais
parti pour chercher un meuble ah oui ça
y est je suis déjà revenu oui regarde
mon meuble
ce miroir
ouais il est beau et bien sûr casimir
mais que vas tu faire d'un si grand
miroir je vais me regarder
j'adore me regarder dans un miroir pour
voir quelles sont mes positions les plus
comiques ou alors comment je suis le
plus beau casimir c'est vraiment
ridicule il faut pas se préoccuper sans
cesse de sa propre personne outre son
physique mais alors à quoi sert un
miroir si on ne peut pas se regarder
dedans ne s'agit pas de ne jamais se
regarder dans une glace par exemple ça
sert le matin pour vérifier si on est
bien coiffée bah oui mais moi j'ai pas
de cheveux
si on sait bien laver les dents c'est
bien que je n'aie pas dedans bon
et si on à la figure propres as tu ne
vas pas me dire que d'une apathie
guerraoui j'ai une figure est justement
j'adore regarder ma figure très
longtemps devant un miroir et faire des
tas de grimaces drôle
et coûtent quasiment aucun signe à
croquer les personnes âgées comme ça tu
n'imagines pas joli passons des heures
devant sa glace en train de faire des
grimaces iman monsieur du snob et entend
mal d'acteurs et je suis même certain cl
tu avais vu il tend à être tous trouvé
vraiment ridicule bon
quand toi non tu n'as pas à discuter non
non je ne discute pas je voudrais
seulement que qui viennent voir quelque
chose quoi encore mais parfaite
dynamisme bien voir là juste là derrière
toi
[Applaudissements]
là
tu comprends juge j'en ai assez ça ne
peut vraiment plus durer alors monsieur
du jeune homme le facteur mmmmh françois
n'arrête pas de dire que je suis le plus
gros de tous les genres de l'île aux
enfants
tu penses que ça n'est pas vrai mais je
sais très bien que c'est vrai je n'ai
pas besoin qu'on me le répète couteau
alors j'ai besoin de ton aide tu veux
que certains non non c'est pas la peine
tu va me servir à arbitrer mon concours
oui je vais leur prouver que je suis le
plus grand
le plus beau
le plus bon danseur soyaux ghazi nuire
on dit pas le culot dit le meilleur
d'enfants guitare ou excuse moi je dis
oui je suis au billet et et puis que je
suis aussi le plus beau le meilleur
chanteur voilà tu sais que françois est
aussi un très bon chanteur je sais mais
pas aujourd'hui il est en roue et
ce n'est pas très honnête enfin si tu
veux puisqu'ils sont méchants avec toi
je vais bien t'aider à leur donner une
petite leçon merci je vais que très
gentille attention je crois qu'il
fallait maintenant on préfère amis c'est
le plus gros rebond sur
les autres caisses et mary j
ma très chère amie vous êtes la boue si
tu étais au courant de cette convocation
quel avenir pour sûr c'est le plus gros
messieurs si vous voulez je suis ici
larbitre d'un concours en quatre
épreuves qui vont vous d'opposer un
concours ailleurs mon cher et me laisser
là parler mais les écoute on m'a bel ami
nous allons commencer immédiatement par
la première épreuve il s'agit de voir
quel est le plus grand dans l'île aux
enfants à enfoncer le plus gros c'est
lui qui l'attestent je n'ai pas dit le
plus gros à bangui le plus grand a
pardonnez moi mademoiselle julie je
m'étais trompé méfiez-vous parents de
taille s'il vous plaît
à moi même et non facteur gpt alors venu
à bout
[Musique]
casimir est le plus grand vraiment vous
trouvez sans aucun doute pour la
deuxième épreuve vous ne bougez pas
c'est un concours de grimaces fait
comparer oui c'est faire des grimaces
pour faire des grimaces et arrêtez de
vous parler à l'oreille début de la
deuxième épreuve
quasi mur vainqueurs
aucune brimade au silence
casimir et le plus beaux de l'île aux
enfants non pas son nom
la troisième épreuve
c'est la danse non messieurs du stop
vous commencez à lire dans votre
disposition des autres mettez-vous de
caunes école de
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à vous facteurs hommes
si l'acteur à
toi françois
racée sérieux
[Musique]
puisqu'il va
aulas
[Musique]
on
stop aux attentes ou casse amours
musicales
[Musique]
il impute genou extraordinaire
casimir et le meilleur danseur de la
manipulation
s'il vous plaît dernière épreuve le show
il vous pouvez chanter ce que nous les
hommes françois prenais mon coeur me
nomme c'est pas juste je suis en ruine
ce n'est pas parce qu'un coureur a mal
aux pieds qu'on supprime les jeux
olympiques de relais dans les vosges ive
et
paillasse
ayasse
alors hydrate et malheur
à vous je suis prêt contre pas
l'entendre les papillons de nuit n'est
pas qu'ils ont de nous les papillons de
lui il s'envole vers la flandre
comme dans la vie sombre où toutes les
couleurs
aux
merci merci les papillons volent
marsouins sionisme a fait tout un vrai
talent trêve de commentaires c'est le
voyons
printemps les petits oiseaux les lille
dallas joie voilà ce qu'on chante
toujours sur le pont
c'est très bien c'est peu mais cette non
non concours à toi casimir musique1
[Musique]
magie
deux manières
tant pis
ils verront camper
ne soyez pas trop
je suis le bon ce qui fait rire
père casimir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
casimir est le meilleur chanteur de
lille
explications pour sûr qu'il ya quelque
chose de pas normal dans ce continent
chers amis nous avons le droit de savoir
et bien voilà la vérité casimir à juste
titre en avait assez des s'entendre
répéter qu'il était le plus gros alors
il a décidé de vous prouver qu'il était
aussi le plus grand le plus beau le
meilleur danseur a le meilleur chanteur
le nul et moi je les aider en trichant
un peu à vous donner cet été tout le
sait a pro tu as eu raison
pour sûr je ne voulais pas lui faire de
la peine c'est tout le monde le pense je
veux bien croire que cette mascarade
était utile qasimi c'est moi
j'ai tiré des écrits les plus gros
pour sur moi non plus nîmois kazemi ans
je vous remercie je suis très ému et
très très content vous êtes de vrais
amis et je suis heureux eh bien nous
allons
au
champion
du coup ça démarre temps à deux trois
quatre cinq parts égales à non au point
galles mais pourquoi parce qu il est
normal quand j'ai une part plus grosse
que les autres alors qu'on quel honneur
et parce qu'en pas parce que je suis le
plus gros
est finie
[Musique]